[Musique]
comme vous savez aujourd'hui nous sommes
en guerre et sa bière à table elle est
mondiale et protéiforme et se doit la
poisse le terrain militaire on le voit
dans la chercher tous les jours les
guerrières les attentats à leur poids
social on a des classes de masse
populaire qu'il veut gagner un peu plus
pour enfants à l'école de mieux manger
et ne pas se questionner tous les autres
comment je vais faire pour passer la
journée et à l'autre côté on avait pu
risquer d'être toujours de manipulation
et enfin on a appris aussi pas de guerre
si le terrain économique
bien évidemment afin de louer cette
guerre économique avec la mondialisation
c'est que les entreprises à travers le
monde évolue dans un environnement
incertain pour battre et mime acrobate
fait nuit on a une concurrence super et
hyper dur et donc le petit producteur
africain doit faire face à ce qui se
passe aux etats-unis où le producteur
est subventionné est ou non la course à
son compte le marché
donc bon gré malgré tout le monde se
débrouille aucun de cette guerre
économique également on a une autre
guerre on sait qu'il faut gagner pour
pouvoir réussir cette guerre c'est la
guerre de l'information et chacun notre
armée notre nom est concerné par cette
vie-là
comme je disais à la guerre économique
mondialisation garder l'information
l'information c'est chacun d'entre nous
qui la fait tous les jours ce que j'aime
manger comme une fois je vais à nous ce
qui importe et qu'elle marc gicquel
match important pour ça les entreprises
en ont besoin pour tous
améliorer les services des produits ti
beaucoup vendent donc ici à ces
déformations leymen pouvons nous leur
donnons bien volontiers pour pouvoir
quand nous achetons des produits qui
nous qui nous cause
en occident ils ont bien compris que
l'information et la nouvelle matière
première qu'ils doivent avoir pour
pouvoir réussir
c'est pour ça qu'on a acquise au gré des
concepts comme big data opendata smart
data et ils sont allés vers les
technologiques et les technologies qui
lui permet de capter tous d'être là sur
nous pour pouvoir mieux nous vendre
encore donc il faut savoir que déjà en
afrique ici les entreprises ne sont pas
très au courant de ce qui est de ce
genre de problématique
ils ne savent pas que l'entreprise il
faut déjà savoir ce qui est une forme à
sa sortie gic et comment distinguer les
différentes informations dont ils ont
besoin pour faire face à la concurrence
qui vient sur le marché où la
concurrence qui vont rencontrer quand
ils vont à l'étranger
commençons par des témoins tels sont les
trois types d'informations on a en
entreprise
on a l'information blanche sa
célébration comme vous avez besoin de
quelque chose vous allez sur google
rapidement vous tapez un mot clé et tout
ce qui sort ces livres c'est facile vous
pouvez l'obtenir l'utiliser comme vous
voulez on a l'information vise qu'à une
information est déjà un peu plus
confidentielle que les maçons blanche
celle là qu'on l'obtenir vous devez
souvent obtenir la permission de celui
qui la détient
et enfin on a une formation noir quelle
est ma stratégie ça l'état après ça par
exemple le secret confidentiel le secret
défense
ah c'est ce qu'il ne faut jamais
divulgué qui que ce soit même entreprise
ici ne savent pas ça et dix villes
beaucoup d'informations sans savoir
pourquoi
parce que d'un elles n'ont pas la
technologie pour protéger ses neuf
nationale moi je pense qu'en afrique il
va faire comme l'occident lancer dans
les technologies pour pouvoir contrer
tout ça
qu'est ce que nous on a fait qu'on a
comme ressources pour protéger nos
informations et points capté de
meilleure des preuves aux cartes et de
meilleures opportunités
on a nos ressources
de par son canton avant de continuer
suis à partie humaine le processus que
les autres africaine peut aussi utiliser
ou obtenir de l'information
on a un coût a reçu ce qu'est la baie
stratégie reste à tj que c'est le
premier pilier de ce qu'on appelle
l'intelligence économique soit mieux
imager ce concept on peut parler d'un
radar pourquoi il les bateaux je suis la
mer un bateau quand il avance sur la mer
ne peut pas naviguer sans savoir où il
va
il ne peut pas naviguer sans savoir ce
qui se passe sous la main s'il ya un
autre bateau qui arrive ou à quelle
vitesse il va il doit obtenir des
informations sur son environnement pour
pouvoir mieux manoeuvrer mieux possible
c'est à sa place elle avait sa musique
pour les organisations elles doivent
savoir ce qui se passe dans un
environnement quand je vais aller sur le
marché qui est déjà si ce marché
comment je peux faire pour quoi gagner
plus de parts de marché quand je peux
aller avec notre partenaire qui est il
qu est ce qu est la réputation est ce
qu'il est c'est mieux pouvoir ne pas moi
même coup les derniers parce
qu'aujourd'hui on sait tous que la
réputation c'est un avantage stratégique
si on la perd notre prisme pouvez très
facilement
en second lieu on a là c'est qu'ils me
la sécurité économie qui parle plus de
la protection des informations qu'on a
une entreprise
aujourd'hui encore je vais monter
pourquoi en afrique on arrive à protéger
nos infos parce qu'on minimise de
collaborateurs donc le côté humain pour
pouvoir cotiser ce 7,7 cette information
on a besoin que les dirigeants sens de
manière dû faire en entreprise
parfois la baie stratégique qui est donc
mort et que j'allais dire ce qui permet
de capter des informations voici trois
niveaux que j'ai remarqué en afrique ne
se passe pas du tout il y en a pas donc
de mon séjour en france chez vous
désirez une feuille des temps de crise
où j'ai vu comme vous les tpe les toutes
petites entreprises font l'effort de
mettre en place ce genre d'outil le
premier outil qu'est auquel rapport
étonnement c'est juste une feuille qu'en
dirigeant met en place et du moins à ses
collaborateurs vous êtes en déposant
semble dans le
vous devez m'aider à capter
l'information ti mais plutôt de prendre
de meilleures décisions
toutes les entreprises tous ensemble
évolué et qu'on qu'en disent tous
ensemble donc réussi avec un petit outil
a fait grandir l'engagement de céder ses
collaborateurs qui se sentent peu
concernés dans le devenir de
l'entreprise
donc cette chape collaborateurs quand il
va sur le terrain travailler c'est qu'il
écartait d'information toute opportunité
qui le petit tapis et l'apprenti
reviennent y compris c'est risqué ça
vous monte au patron et le pas
consciente et à voici quelque chose
d'intéressant ce que je peux c'est là
que je peut causer et régaler volant
coquilles le deuxième point c'est le
réseau professionnel en afrique on a une
force que la tradition orale on se passe
des choses de bouche à oreille c'est une
force que nous devons utiliser le réseau
professionnel comme je le dis les
propositions ne comprennent pas ce que
c'est on pense que mon réseau c'est
lassant de mes contacts dames ont
téléphoné ou c'est la semaine de
contacts sur facebook ce qui est faux le
besoin national
vous ne vous pose la question qui je
peux contacter quand j'ai un projet que
je veux réaliser avec je bataille sur
des centres d'intérêts fort que je peux
appeler je sais qu'une vanne offrir son
aide pas s'il est capable et lui aussi
celles qui en retour dès qu'il aura
besoin de moi et j'ai des infos pour
l'aider il peut compter sur moi la
seconde a réuni son équipe au septième
position de critiquer quelqu'un celui la
partie de mon réseau conventionnel
troisièmement comment taille d'un dédain
faut aussi nous pouvons faire c'est
diallo collaborateurs je vais des infos
sur la concurrence sur les marchés
la sotiba mondial midi par exemple va
manger une telle zone où la foule est le
concurrent elle est logique parce que
les collaborateurs du compliment manche
dans la zone aci thouars l' écoute les
conversations par ses amis nantes milieu
mur les déplacés et 10 mangent entre eux
et discute des fois des projets de
l'entreprise
c'est des moments où on a beaucoup
d'informations très intéressantes
jamie enquête incognito c'est un peu
aller jouer à l'agent secret mais c'est
tout à fait légal
alors la sécurité économie humaine
encore une fois parce que ce que je vous
dis on lui sait comment faire de
l'économique comment gagner des
opportunités mais on se balance une
autre force qui est l'humain l'ubs est
alors l'activité économique se protéger
vos informations
vous savez on minimise beaucoup de
collaborateurs en afrique celle des
entreprises où le patron arrive on voit
le convoi les clubs est arrivée en
courant pour aller prendre la valise où
aller il faut aller dit vous n'avez pas
trop discret presque pas quand c'est pas
moche pas que les mots de management
beaucoup évolué il faut pouvoir
permettre aux autres collaborateurs
même si son effet planification de se
sentir à l'aise parce que la quantité
les ménages restant le chauffeur du
dirigeant les commerciaux qu'on en voit
sur le terrain tous âges et tous les ans
des personnes là c'est les gens qui
traversent votre entreprise petite tape
beaucoup de ce qui se passe chez vous ce
ne serait ce que les premières cellules
commerciales qui doit à l'iss le dernier
cherchait des contrats et venir il
s'agissait pour nous informer de votre
produit
il s'est départi plaie qui ne doit pas
du bord mais vous l'avez pas sensibilisé
vous les masses péter tout le tout les
jours vous lui crie dessus pas à quoi
ces résultats
celui là les compliments dehors va les
proposer peut-être 10000 points de plus
que son salaire il va livrer toutes les
infos si votre copine
il va vendre aux entreprises à bas prix
la vie donc ne serait ce que améliorer
le comportement qu'on a envers nos
collaborateurs revaloriser l'humain ce
qu'on a nous même embauché leur faire
confiance pour qu'il n'aura pas de
l'info et naturellement ils se sont
fidélisés l'entreprise et protège
naturellement nos collaborateurs une
autre vie plutôt vous en gagnent
beaucoup sans dépenser un fond ce n'est
pas forcément la crise financière
j'espère que lui même a ressenti plus
concernés par votre entreprise
même lui reconnaître une bonne action
lui dit à ce que tu as fait la dernière
fois c'est beaucoup aimé ça m'a permis
d'un produit conclut tel contraste nous
fait quelque chose la reconnaissance
c'est quelque chose qui fait l'humain ce
centième tour entreprises
business et bassines autrement pour vous
donc après avoir mieux fait en politique
vous portez votre humaine meilleurs il
faut les sensibiliser
vous vous rappelez on n'a pas les trois
types d'informations et faucons des
autres que no doubt africaine détecte en
leur sein qu'est ce type de formation
quelles sont les animations que je peux
dire les stayers est ce que je ne dois
pas dire et le communiqué elle couvre
collaborateurs vous dites est le type de
faux quelle que soit la situation
on ne le dit pas beaucoup ne subissent
pas qu'on n'embauche qu en afrique on
l'attend de lui qui produisent du
résultat on oublie les formations en
double et sensibilisation on veut qu'ils
proposent ils produisent il est censé
donner des résultats à savoir que nous
mêmes on doit toujours actualiser ses
connaissances pour qu'ils puissent
améliorer ses résultats
une 3 une troisième phase
l influence une entreprise africaine
souffre beaucoup nous servir pour les
offres d'emplois des producteurs par
exemple de l'adventure peu d'éléments
que les producteurs d'ananas ne peuvent
plus exporter un type d'ananas
spécifique du béton produit au bénin
vers l'étranger mais ça ils ont appris
du jour au lendemain parce que l'union
européenne de l'autre côté c'est le
nouveau matin a dit tellement de vent
plus le territoire a changé la nomme
donc personne n'a pas de l'info ou nos
petits deux reprises à nous or les
entreprises ont le droit de s'asseoir
aux tables pour se négocier les normes
mais elles ne savent pas qu'elles ont le
droit d'aller là où les nominés mais
aussi pour faire entendre leur voix
donc méfiance c'est pour dire quand les
par la table des négociations
là où les gens se négocie près les lois
les lois qui s'appliquent à vous aussi
vous êtes forcément menu des nominations
on va parler de vous même si vous n'êtes
pas là à passer car leur point bas ait
décidé à servir et non pour lui dire
qu'il avait bon matin et ne peut plus
faire du business toute sa production
est bloqué et ne plus passer c'est
beaucoup de manque à gagner
donc il ya toute une constante tout un
processus comme jadis appelée l'audience
économies qu'on peut mettre en place
simplement en plus à base d'outils
gratuits
ce conte et en afrique les divisions
beaucoup ce qui est gratuit si vous lui
dites j'ai un projet quelque chose pour
douar des 6 un petit système des petits
outils qui vont remettre des cartes et
d'un coup tout en mobilisant des
collaborateurs et tout en protégeant nos
actuellement des formations ouvert et
qu'il vous en faire beaucoup plus
alors c'est un parc et son parcours
parce que pour finir je vois seulement
par les entreprises mais aussi de
certaines en tant qu'individu surtout
les jeunes par exemple des jeunes qu'ils
soient étudiants ou en recherche
d'emploi
lorsqu'on parle autrement dit à un
recruteur je suis diplômée en
communication ou marketing
il va dépoter estimates et compétences
tout ça mais les cv il m'a peut-être 100
pour un poste
les soldes déguisés en reçoit 1000 j'ai
l'honneur de demander quelque chose
le néo zélandais il y en a plein sur la
table
non pour commencer différencier le point
d'être devenu défini ci a misé pour
décrocher mon emploi jusqu'à du
recruteur c'est oui je n'étais pas du
conseil j'aime assez d'informations en
conseil mais j'ai aussi l'aptitude de
pouvoir vous aider à mettre en place un
système gratuit qui permettra de fédérer
l'ensemble de vos collaborateurs de
capter les efforts qui vous permettront
de mieux décidé de mieux comprendre son
environnement et de prophéties vos
informations
donc parce qu'on a dit qu'on est en
guerre en guerre
il faut avancer donc attaquer tout en se
protégeant en même temps dont j'ai un
système pour vous gratuit que je peux
vous exposer et mettre en place tout de
suite les recruteurs avaient tendu
l'oreille à mon discours est mon cv est
passé en dessous de la pile de cv qui
avait sa table c'est comme ça que j'ai
pu décrocher mon emploi et le distingué
parmi beaucoup d'autres jeunes
donc je propose aussi la science
économique comme une nouvelle compétence
que les jeux ne peut mettre en place
peut ajouter à leurs bagages on peut la
prendre cette fois-ci internet
mieux de prendre une petite formation en
plus pour pouvoir améliorer son bagage
l'employabilité c'est pour le cadre
encore une fois c'est pareil on peut
améliorer son parcours est allé dire aux
dirigeants à se trouver une nouvelle
j'ai trouvé une nouvelle idée pour un
parfait encore plus notre quizz j'ai
trouvé une nouvelle idée qui nous
permettra de capter plus d'opportunités
tout en protégeant et le trouver le
moyen d'aller influencé notre
environnement plus toujours plus gagner
des opportunités et en plus
l'organisation c'est tout simple lorsque
vous verrez il ya des petites des petits
outils qu'on utilise en tant qu'économie
ya des outils comme vous savez tous les
matins on va suivre plus de sites les
blogs des sites web qui permettent de
capter des fautes on a besoin on va
subsiste qu'un incident c'est comme ça
que j'ai fait au début lorsque chéri de
l'emploi il y avait dix mille sites
d'emploi et j'allais gérer fiq 10 15 20
si tous les jours lorsque j'ai découvert
le jazz économique que je me suis formé
est un outil un seul outil qui
permettrait qui me mettaient de suivre
tous les sites et j'avais l'habitude de
taper tous les chômeurs donateurs en un
seul lieu
j'avais tous ces sites là et les
armateurs spécialisé nature est
automatiquement
non je n'avais plus qu'un seul outil
avril le matin vous êtes connecté au
monde entier ça me permettrait d'une
vais m'organiser
si vous aviez pu détecter plus
facilement l'offre d'emploi braquage
avait conduit et qui m'a permis d'avoir
un emploi qui gère aujourd'hui donc
c'est à dire ceux qui peuvent être
demandés par fait le parcours du pince à
un parfait le mien vous réduisez un
emploi qui sont entrés dans la vie
active j'ai plus de moyens et de prêt à
dire tout ce qui est autour de moi donc
j'espère que les jeunes qui sont ici
présents pour en faire de même et
pouvoir encore une fois un parfum de
parc ou aussi pareil pour les cadres en
entreprise et la dizaine d'entreprises
qui sont ici c'est un excellent outil
qui vous
qu'ils aient beaucoup gratuit et qu'on a
fait on peut utiliser si on prend la
peine de mieux considérer l'être humain
qui à côté de nous et le 10 puis la
peine de se baisser pour eddy bonjour
c'est à côté de chez eux et c'est moi le
patron d'entreprise mais on peut se
regarder dans les yeux on se serre la
main du matin merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]